Hello.
I am Terry Fisher.
This is the
introduction to a series
of 12 lectures on copyright.
My hope, in these
lectures, is to provide you
the following things:
First, an understanding
of the basic principles
of copyright law;
Second, an appreciation
of the ways
in which that law affects, for
better and worse, creativity
and innovation in a wide variety
of artistic and technical
fields.
(To that end, I will
be providing you,
along the way,
illustrations of the ways
that copyright works in
literature; music; film;
photography; graphic art;
software; comedy; fashion;
architecture; and so forth.)
Third, I will try to provide
you a critical understanding
of the main theories of
copyright by which I mean,
the arguments, developed
over several centuries
by economists, philosophers,
and political theorists,
concerning the purposes or
functions of the copyright
system.
These theories are not mere
matters of academic curiosity
and dispute.
Copyright law is
changing very fast,
in part in an attempt to
address new technologies,
and the lawmakers who
are making the changes
are influenced by
and in turn help
to shape the competing
theories of copyright.
So, to understand
where the law is going
and certainly if you wish
to affect its trajectory
you need to know a fair
amount about theory.
This bring me to the fourth
and last of the ambitions:
By the end of these
lectures, I hope
to have increased your
ability and confidence
to make informed judgments
concerning how, if at all,
the copyright system
should be reformed.
SO, TO SUMMARIZE:
copyright law;
its impact on creativity;
theories of copyright;
and ways in which the
system could be improved
those are the general
themes I will be addressing.
The themes are
intertwined, of course,
and I will try to identify, in
the lectures, the relationships
among them.
The topics of the 12
lectures, in which
I will be addressing
these themes
are set forth on your screen.
This first lecture is
called "the foundations
of copyright law."
Once I am finished with
the introductory material,
I will discuss three
aspects of copyright
that can be thought
of as fundamental:
--the concept of originality;
--the crucial distinctions in
copyright law between ideas,
facts, and expression;
--and the system of
multilateral treaties
that constrain the freedom
of almost all countries
when shaping and administering
their national copyright
systems.
Along the way, I will discuss
some current controversies
that those basic
principles affect.
The 2nd lecture will
examine and contrast
two theories of copyright
law specifically
the fairness theory,
which is especially
prominent in countries (like
Great Britain, the United
States, and Australia)
that have been influenced
by the common-law
legal tradition;
and the personality
or personhood theory,
which tends to be somewhat
more prominent in countries
(including Continental
Europe and Latin America)
that have been influenced
by the civil-law tradition.
In the 3rd lecture, we will
return to legal doctrine.
Specifically, I will survey
the kinds of original works
that are subject to
copyright protection.
Some of these (such as
novels, musical compositions,
and films) will be unsurprising.
Others (such as software,
fictional characters,
and three-dimensional
useful objects)
may be somewhat
more eye-opening.
The 4th lecture will
concentrate on the most complex
of the copyright
theories: the welfare
theory, an outgrowth of
the philosophic tradition
of utilitarianism.
As we will see, this theory
has growing influence,
certainly among scholars and
increasingly among lawmakers,
in all jurisdictions
in the world.
The 5th lecture will consider
the complex set of rules that
define the term, "author"
-- and identify the persons
and organizations that
qualify as authors.
The 6th lecture, entitled
"the mechanics of copyright,"
considers how the copyright
system works in practice.
I will discuss, for example,
--what, if anything,
an author must do
to secure copyright protection;
--the preconditions for bringing
a copyright infringement suit;
--how long copyrights last;
--how the rights
associated with copyright
are transferred from
one person to another;
--and how the copyright
system attempts
to shield authors (or their
families) against exploitation.
The 7th and 8th lectures
will examine in some detail
the legal rights that a
copyright owner enjoys.
The primary entitlements,
we will see,
are the exclusive rights to
reproduce, modify, distribute,
or perform their works.
We will examine the scope
of each of those rights --
and the equally important
list of specific exceptions
and limitations
upon those rights,
which are designed to
protect the public"s interest
in enjoying and transforming
copyrighted materials.
The 9th lecture will
examine the general defense
to copyright infringement
known variously
as fair use and fair dealing.
This is among the most
controversial and unstable
aspects of the copyright system.
How this doctrine evolves
in the near future
will have a big impact on
journalism, music, film,
graphic art, and so forth.
In the 10th lecture, we will
return for the last time
to copyright theory,
examining an approach that
seems gradually to be growing
in influence in many countries.
It goes by various
names, but I will
use the term cultural theory.
In the 11th lecture, we will
examine 2 important supplements
to the set of legal rights
enjoyed by copyright owners.
The first of these
is the doctrine
of secondary liability, which
enables copyright owners
sometimes to control the
behavior of organizations that
do not themselves engage
in copyright infringement,
but rather facilitate the
infringing behavior of others.
(Included in this group are some
quaint organizations, like flea
markets, and some modern ones,
like peer-to-peer filesharing
systems.)
The second supplement
is the recent addition
to the copyright
system of prohibitions
on the circumvention of
technological protection
measures.
That cumbersome term
refers to legal efforts
to increase the ability
of copyright owners
to control uses of their
works through encryption.
Finally, in the 12th lecture, I
will survey the legal remedies
that are available to
a copyright owner whose
rights have been abridged.
As is probably obvious, there
is a color scheme to this list.
The lectures described
using a black font focus
on copyright law and
its applications.
The lectures described
using a red font focus
on theoretical or
policy considerations.
When discussing details
concerning copyright law,
I will most often make
reference to the rules
currently in force
in the United States
partly because I know
that system best,
and partly because,
for better or worse,
US law is influential in
many other jurisdictions.
But I will also devote
significant attention
to the differences
between US law
and the legal systems
in other countries.
Now, a few words about the
logistics of these lectures:
Each will last
roughly 90 minutes.
A fair amount of graphic
and audiovisual materials
will company the presentations.
Consequently, it
will be best if you
view recordings of the
lectures on a computer
or on a screen of some sort.
You could, of course,
just listen to them,
but you would be missing
much illustrative material.
The most important of the
supplementary visual materials
will be two maps
I have prepared.
One covers the main
features of copyright law.
The other covers the main
features of copyright theory.
Because the maps themselves
and my use of them are unusual,
I will say a few more
words about this feature.
The heart of the first
map looks like this.
As you might imagine,
the "plus" signs
identify opportunities
for expansion.
If you click on a "plus"
sign, it will open additional
branches of the map -- like so.
These icons identify links.
Some of the links will
open slide presentations
that I have prepared.
Others lead to copies of
statutes or judicial decisions
-- or to supplementary materials
prepared by other scholars
or lawyers that are accessible
through the Internet.
The second map, which examines
Intellectual Property Theory,
works the same way.
Both of the maps were created
using the Mindmanager software
program, and I will be
displaying the Mindmanager
versions on your screens
during these lectures.
If you want to explore
the maps at your leisure,
you can gain access to them
through the CopyrightX website
or through my personal
homepage, the address of which
is: tfisher.org.
If you want to edit the
maps, for example, to add
your own notes or to
supplement the links
you will need a software
program of some sort.
You can, of course,
use Mindmanager --
which you can obtain from
the website for Mindjet --
but it is expensive.
Other programs that can be used
to import and edit the maps
include ithoughts, which is
available for a modest price,
and XMind, an
open-source program
that is available for free.
Last but not least, if you
want to explore the maps
but not edit them, the
easiest way to do so
is to use the "flash"
based versions,
which are available on
the CopyrightX website.
To use those, you do not
need any software at all;
they will open in
most modern browsers.
Together, the two maps contains
all of my lecture notes
for all 12 of these lectures,
plus links to a wide variety
of additional materials.
The result is that they contain
-- or provide access to --
a large amount of
information and commentary.
However, it is
important that you
understand their limitations.
In particular, you should
not think of the first map
as the equivalent of a
treatise on copyright law;
it is certainly not a
comprehensive survey
of the law, and it contains some
opinionated material that would
be inappropriate in a treatise.
Rather it is a pedagogic aid --
a device intended to facilitate
your understanding of --
and capacity to remember --
the main features of
the copyright system.
I modify both of the
maps with some frequency.
Most often, I do this to
take into account changes
in copyright
statutes or treaties
or new judicial decisions.
But I also sometimes
revise the maps
when I change my mind
on a particular issue
or when another commentator
deploys a novel argument.
Accordingly, if you find the
maps useful in the future,
you should probably check
the CopyrightX website
to make sure that you have
the most current versions.
I will try to keep the
maps reasonably up to date
as long as I am able.
Finally, if you have
suggestions concerning
the content of either map
(bearing in mind, of course,
their limited purposes),
feel free to e-mail
me using the address listed
on the CopyrightX website.
The same principle
applies to these lectures.
If you have suggestions
concerning how they might be
improved -- please let me
know, by sending a message
to the same email address.
This concludes the
introduction to lecture #1.
In the next segment,
I will take up
the first of the substantive
topics in the course:
the concept of originality.